We can figure this out by looking at the roots, or the zeros of this function.
We found before that they were 2, 9 plus i and 9 minus i. Now, these breakeven
points are going to be actual points on the graph. And remember, since our
graph is only plotting real values of x and real values of y, 9 plus i and 9
minus i, are not actual x values on the graph. That means the only real x
intercept is at x equals 2. So there's only one break even point, and as I just
said the value of x at that point is 2. Now remember, x in this equation, stood
for thousands of dollars spent on advertising. So Grant doesn't just need to
spend $2 to break even, he needs to spend $2,000. He'd probably rather spend
two but unfortunately, advertising is pretty expensive.